Man of Steel is sort of unintentionally
this brilliant criticism of the modern
state of America I mean Superman is
basically the avatar of America right
truth justice and the American Way all
that he grew up in Kansas he's as
American as apple pie it's right there
in the inherent conceit the American Way
do things the American Way maybe this is
what people mean when they're saying
that Superman and Man of Steel is acting
out of character they're saying he's not
properly American he's not doing things
the American Way he just marches around
the globe exercising extra judicial
powers in pursuit of a single terrorist
cell while ignoring virtually all
collateral damage also he basically
skits diplomacy entirely I'm surprised
he didn't say I don't negotiate with
terrorists before he punched Zod and
effectively for the hundredth time now
that probably sounds a little cynical
but it's not limited just to Superman
Tony Stark does the same thing marches
around the globe leaving a wake of
destruction in the name of America and
capitalism presumably he has a change of
heart about selling weapons and crap
when he sees his missiles ending up in
the hands of terrorists but then decides
that nigh invincible future-tech fueling
horrifying new vision of one-sided
warfare isn't the problem the problem is
other people having weapons also
citizens having weapons of mass
destruction that they use to wage a
one-man extrajudicial war of conscience
regardless of the sovereignty of other
nations is only a problem if those
people aren't American that's not even
touching on Batman but Batman is not all
that bad right sure he tapped into every
cell phone in Gotham but he was only
listening not keeping a permanent record
and besides if the citizens weren't
criminals what did they have to hide
this is of course after he forcibly
extradite a foreign national in the
middle of the night and is given free
rein to torture a man for information
the scary thing about Batman is that
they have characters outright say that
these things are kind of bad scary ideas
but then they tell us it's all okay
I mean Fox thinks this is a terrible
idea
done abomination but
it's all ok it's all ok because
terrorists I mean that's the scary thing
about these movies it's always justified
one way or another there's a reason to
say it's ok they had to it was the Joker
they had to Superman had to stop Zod
because Zod had weapons of mass
destruction and sent scary videos to the
media you're all at risk you're all
going to die and only Superman in the
American Way can save you he had to it's
all ok it's always worth the cost as
much as Fox complains it doesn't matter
because Batman is vindicated it all
works well the torture doesn't but the
rest of it does the implication in The
Dark Knight is that massive violations
of civil liberties by a vigilante no
less are all ok as long as you pinky
swear to tear down the system once
you've got what you were looking for the
message in these movies is that what we
really want what America wants and needs
is a vigilante system of justice where
those with power are allowed to do
whatever they feel they need to
regardless of the cost because it's all
ok it's always worth the cost I mean
these movies start off with the
assumption that the rule of law is an
irritating formality my favorite part of
Man of Steel is when the American
military treats Canadian sovereignty
like an annoying detail that they'd be
better off without it probably be more
fair to say that Man of Steel is
anti-american in that it's fetishism of
American Authority demonstrates a
frightening recklessness toward
civilians and other nations now jingoism
is nothing new and neither is the whole
America Saves of the world's storyline
but it's changed it it used to be just
be kind of arrogant like everyone
sitting around waiting for America to
fix whatever problem the world has
gotten into it's from the Americans
they want to organize a
counter-offensive about bloody time and
then America would come up with some
nifty solution that would bring everyone
together now it's different president
Bill Pullman felt bad about nuking an
empty city that was on the verge of
being destroyed by aliens I mean sure
the city looked empty but who knows how
many people are trapped by circumstance
old people who can't or won't leave
their homes poor people with no means of
evacuating search and rescue teams
looking for stragglers we don't even
know them we don't even know if they
exist but may our children forgive us
now they justify the damage the
casualties the collateral damage it's
all worth it because we're all going to
die and they are protecting us it's all
okay spider-man detonates a chemical
bomb over New York but it's okay sure no
one really knows what effect that
completely untested drug would have in a
wide population but you do what you have
to do then he dropped a radio tower on a
crowded street he didn't need to do that
and I guess he didn't even want to but
that's what happens it's just the cost
of doing business those people shouldn't
have stood so close to justice it wasn't
always that way
spider-man used to show us the human
toll things would fall and would see
them land things would get damaged even
by spider-man's own hand but it was in
the process of preventing greater damage
in spider-man to the messages that
heroes save people an amazing spider-man
the messages that heroes catch bad guys
some people would say there's no
difference I guess the police agree
because the first time they engage
Connors they open up on him with
automatic weapons like it's a gangland
massacre and they continue to pump
bullets into his body after he's down
it's cool though he's the bad guy and
see it was justified he regenerates
isn't hindsight wonderful the Avengers
are technically the Avengers initiative
a specific sub organization of shield
which is explicitly an institution of
the American government in fact their
strategic homeland intervention
enforcement and logistics division
strategic homeland intervention homeland
defense sure seems to involve a lot of
armed operations on foreign soil that's
all before you even get to the 160
billion dollars of damage that they do
to Manhattan it seems like the primary
use of a building is to RAM some
thing into it I don't know why you would
though I mean it doesn't ever seem to do
anything the building just gets wrecked
also it's not like these buildings are
empty the evacuation started like five
minutes ago the police didn't even start
hustling until Captain America told them
how to do their jobs because existing
power structures are incompetent and
what we really need is a small group of
people with unlimited power and
resources making all the decisions with
no practical oversight and then there's
Superman the damage to Metropolis to the
global economy is estimated at two
trillion dollars with close to 1.5
million casualties a trillion dollars is
almost impossible to comprehend one
trillion dollars is enough money to
provide clean water Basic Education
functional roads high-speed Internet
basic health care and apprentice
training in a trade to basically
everyone on the planet not one of those
things all of those things like I said
it's almost impossible to comprehend but
it's always worth the cost if you don't
believe that you just don't realize how
powerful Zod really is that's the
problem you're off message Superman is
the only answer to Zod and it's always
worth the cost
and after Zod is dead well don't worry
I'm sure they'll think of something for
the sequel some reason to keep Superman
around and if that starts to fall flat
they can just reboot the whole thing put
on a new coat of paint and cut out all
the annoying parts where the heroes show
remorse or doubt the value of their own
existence or make a suspect that they
might just be part of the problem to
begin with because don't worry it's all
okay
it's always worth the cost
and rapture
you